Sweat! I sweat you sweat we all sweat ! Well some men sweat a little bit more than
others right? But still we all sweat and
it sucks! It stinks, it stains clothes and it
just sucks. Well unless you use the right
deodorant. Especially for you young guys
out there you have to develop a habit of
putting on deodorant or antiperspirant
as soon as you finish the shower. Why?
Well then you'll never find yourself in
that embarrassing situation where you're
at a place and people remember you as
that guy that's stinks. All right so what
is the best antiperspirant or deodorant
out there for men? Well that's what we're
gonna talk about in this video so let's
get to it!
Hey guys! if this is your first time here on my
channel. Welcome!! I'm Daniel, consider subscribing and also clicking
that notification bell so you won't miss
any of the next videos. Now let's start
with the first deodorant
Dove stain defense antiperspirant. Now
Dove impressed me a lot of their men's
products over the years, if you look at
the quality and the low price and the
antiperspirant is no different. It's
very good and it protects you against
those ugly yellow stains that you really
don't want, it smells fresh and it is
also good to use if you have sensitive
skin. All right let's move on to the next
one
The Underarm Deodorant Stick. Now this is
one of the best ones out there on the
market. Why? Well because it actually
works the way that they advertise it. Not
only that but it has organic ingredients
that detox your body and nourish your
skin. So basically it's a natural organic
deodorant that works great. I'll add it for you in the video description below so you
can check it out. It's got over 2000 of a
happy customer reviews from people like
you and me that tried it out already and they actually give you a 30-day money-back
guarantee if it is not the best
deodorant that you've ever used. Now that
says a lot! Alright, let's move on to
the next one
Alright we are at the last one
and the last one is my favorite
Nivea invisible black and white. This guy!
It's never ever let me down, it's an
antiperspirant and so it will help you
to sweat less and it will protect you
from those ugly yellow and white stains
on your clothes that you don't want. I
usually get three of them at the same
time so then I'll know I'm set for the
next few months and I don't need to
worry about getting any new
antiperspirant. So this guy smells good
it is cheap and it works great! I will add it for you in the video description to check it out
If you like the video give it a thumbs up subscribe
and I'll see you in the next video
cheers guys
you